where did the coronavirus come from
social media is arrived with claims it
was weaponized in a secret laboratory
designed to put a stop to exponential
global population growth others say the
new 5g mobile phone technology helps the
virus spread these pictures call for the
destruction of 5g transmitter masts
[Music]
pandemics offer the perfect environment
to encourage the spread of conspiracy
theories
powerful forces are said to be behind
the pandemic there is talk of enforced
vaccinations and blanket state
surveillance the monstrous microbe as a
global conspiracy an evil plot to rule
the world a billionaire who wants to get
even richer with the cure to a virus he
created I'm sorry to let you down folks
that's Hollywood this crisis is
spectacular enough without having to be
spiced up with conspiracy theories is
this the new normal
widespread protests against lockdown
measures in Germany Britain and the US
and conspiracy theorists are among the
most vocal they believe secret
organizations are behind the corona
virus outbreak taking advantage it's
just a means to an end and they're
pursuing a different agenda how can we
deal with such confusing statements Pia
Lamberty has written a book analyzing
the psyche of conspiracy theory
supporters she says it's an instinct to
be more secure and be in control this
situation where we have so little
control the conspiracy theorist provides
a perceived structure stability and make
sense of everything
the virus is invisible it's an invisible
threat you can understand the conspiracy
theorist you can't demonstrate against a
virus that wouldn't help but if you
think somebody's behind it you can take
action there have long been conspiracy
theories the assassination of John F
Kennedy by intelligence agencies is
among them
one suggest the death of Princess Diana
was a long time in the planning
they say the contrails of jets are in
reality trails of toxic chemicals and
the September 11th attacks were carried
out by the US government supporters of
the queuing on conspiracy theories that
have proliferated on online message
boards believe that many celebrities are
involved in a pedophile ring I always
speak out against calling them crazy or
stupid people that's not true but I
think you have to be careful not to get
into too much discussion about it we
have to understand their fears they are
all just concerned citizens at the same
time such bad images are being spread
Bill Gates is currently a key target of
hatred the conspiracy theorists alleged
the Microsoft founder helped develop the
corona virus and he even wants to
implant chips and people to check their
health the German conspiracy theorists
Ken Jepsen has railed against gates on
YouTube with more than 3 million views
whether you have to wear a mask or
whether this country is in lockdown or
not that's now determined by Bill and
Melinda Gates we deal with people who
refuse to listen if they fend off any
criticism when everything becomes so
diffuse I think that during the past few
weeks our awareness has increased and we
can say oh we got a problem will the
ranks of the conspiracy theorists grow
larger and louder in the coming weeks
one thing is clear there will always be
conspiracy theories especially in times
of crisis
Mehcad buddha is from the University of
Tubingen he investigates conspiracy
theories and joins us now
just how much truth is there or is there
any truth to any of these conspiracy
theories well there is very little truth
to virtually all of these conspiracy
theories of course there is the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation
of course the virus originated in Wuhan
of course there are people who are
working on a vaccine against that virus
but I think that's basically it so
conspiracy theories make what Richard
hosts that are called a cure asleep in
the imagination fairly early on and then
basically leave the facts behind or
construct their own facts we've all had
quite a lot of time in isolation to
think about these things haven't we
but tell me just how new these Kuroda
conspiracy theories are actually they
are not that new in that most of the
corona conspiracy theories no matter
which version and where they're Maryland
at the moment all over the world they're
usually only the latest chapter in much
larger and longer conspiracy narratives
so the villains to a certain degree were
already clear and now corona is just the
latest chapter the newest episode in
that story so I'm not that new after all
who's behind them though behind the
conspiracy theories yeah well it's
people who genuinely believe that they
have found out what is really going on
that's one of the major differences
between conspiracy theories and fake
news with fake news we usually assume
that the people who put these stories
into circulation are doing so cynically
they know that they are lying with
conspiracy theories this is possible -
some people are cynical about them and
they just circulate them for political
advantages or economic gain but most
people who are behind the corona
conspiracy theories and these are people
all over the world from the left from
the right people
who think of themselves as moderates
they are genuinely convinced that they
are doing a service to mankind by
exposing what is allegedly really going
on Michelle isn't there a lot more to
this than just conspiracy theories I
mean doesn't this boil down to a crisis
of trust I think it's a symptom of a
crisis of trust and I think that we see
a larger crisis of trust and a
fragmentation that is running through
Western societies particularly well
particularly pointedly with regard to
conspiracy theories because here we have
two publics that actually are looking
suspiciously at each other there's one
public that is worried about conspiracy
theories and there is one public that is
worried about conspiracies and these
public's look at each other they watch
each other and realize that the other is
out of touch with what they realize is
reality so from the perspective of the
reality that you and I are in of course
there is a problem with trust there is a
problem with trust and traditional
expertise in science in politicians that
makes solving the problems that we have
to solve as countries and as the whole
world really probably really difficult
we brushed over some of the theories our
other national differences yes there
definitely national differences so for
example in Germany people now most
people believe that the virus either is
completely harmless or does not exist at
all because things went actually quite
well here the lockdown work there
weren't that many people who died and
therefore the alleged plot is to take
our civil rights away and to introduce a
global vaccination program in France for
example where there were many more
people who died most people believed
that the virus was actually constructed
in a laboratory that is a biological
weapon in the u.s. people linked it to
the qn on the deep state conspiracy
theory so many people on the right thing
that is a plot to actually
heard president Donald Trump and to
prevent him being reelected chef Botta
very interesting stuff thank you very
much for joining us fish I bought her
from the University of Tubingen he
investigates conspiracy theories thank
you thank you so much for having me and
time for your questions on the
coronavirus here's our science
correspondent Derek Williams
how was toy am able to contain the
spread of covered 19 so successfully
Taiwan was badly affected by the SARS
outbreak back in 2003 it killed over a
hundred and eighty people there its
mortality rate was was higher than
anywhere else in the world after that
the islands government put detailed
plans in place to deal with possible
future outbreaks and they kicked in very
quickly after the very first reports of
a of a new pneumonia in wuhan days or
even weeks before most of us have even
heard of this disease the actions that
were taken appear to have contained
kovat 19 very well they included border
controls a 14 day quarantine on
international arrivals closing venues
where large numbers of people could
gather and a ban on the export of
protective masks so far there have been
fewer than 500 cases of kovat 19 on the
island and just and just a handful of
deaths how effective is social distance
in preventing the spread of covered 19 a
research team in Germany looked into
this and found strong correlations
between the introduction of specific
interventions and the spread of kovat 19
in the country using established models
they came to some key conclusions not
least that social distancing measures
began to really have an impact two weeks
after they were implemented which which
dovetails with predictions involving the
SARS Cove - incubation period
the team also tried to break down
exactly which measures had which effects
and concluded that that growth rates
were slowed most dramatically by
prohibiting large public gatherings
later decisions to close schools and
then non-essential stores during what
was called the country's lockdown light
also had measurable effects the team
concluded that it took all three
measures to to flatten Germany's curve
so quickly is the body of someone who's
died from covered 19 infectious and if
so for how long
scientists are still working on
answering this question but the safest
assumption is yes bodies can pose a risk
but a low one that's because the virus
remains viable on other surfaces for
varying amounts of time so so there's no
reason to think it wouldn't remain
viable on a body as well research
carried out in this direction during the
SARS epidemic also implied that bodily
fluids from someone who had died from
that disease could remain infectious for
up to 96 hours that said the evidence
indicates that kovat 19 is spread mostly
through respiration and droplets and
less so through direct physical contact
with surfaces so the body of someone who
has died from the disease is generally
being viewed as less of a risk for
transmission than a living patient
you